musique la capacité de vraiment transmet
à rome humanité dans sa manière
on ne sont pas le frontières
[Musique]
nous on a décidé de faire quelque chose
collaboratif
[Musique]
le
m
[Musique]
alors voilà un court extrait de la bande
annonce de ce film concert où on voit
naître une oeuvre un opéra un conte
autochtone millénaire à la rencontre la
musique et les six qu'il soit ça se
passe dans le grand nord du québec
la culture autochtone à la rencontre de
la culture des blancs le partage la
réconciliation sont les grands thèmes de
ce film cette rencontre nous donne
chaque à pêche documentaire un film
signé roger frappier et justin kingsley
un documentaire qui nous transporte dans
le grand nord où l'eau est saine de kent
nagano et est parti en tournée à
l'automne 2000 le 18 c'est sa deuxième
tournée dans le grand nord maïs trop
voulais y retourner
et puis à demander la création de cet
opéra de chambre tout à fait unique une
musique contemporaine en studio avec
nous ce soir pour un vendredi culturel
roger frappier co réalisateur avec
justin kingsley et producteur de films
roger frappier bonsoir bonsoir et marc
boyer du musicologue adjoint bras droit
de kent nagano chargée de ce projet on
vous voit dans le documentaire également
marque on va voir un autre extrait de ce
film
avec leurs 15 ans voyage où on voit
beaucoup de choses ont fait le tour du
mans on voit des grandes villes des
belles salles de concert puis le nunavik
c'est comme la place la plus loin qu'on
est allé même si j'étais chez nous c'est
là où est-ce qu'on était le plus en
dehors de ma zone de confort
on est dans la même province mais c'est
quand je sais c'est comme une eau
planète
une autre est passé bien chez nous
d'abord pour te dire qui et xhaka pêche
remarque jacques la pêche c'est c'est un
personnage de la mythologie cris et nous
c'est un partage qui apparaissent dans
plusieurs histoires et c'est en commun
on l'appelle un fripon et trickster en
anglais c'est comme un clown c'est le
fils de dieu il a plein de pouvoirs
magiques et tomson highway le
librettiste de tshakapesh l'opéra qu'on
a créé nous a créé une histoire qui
était à moitié
inspiré de la mythologie puis l'autre
moitié inspiré de son imagination pour
épier le créateur donc à thomas
donc oui tomson highway comme sur la wii
on va donc les plantaire a créé l'écrit
lui-même et 18 nitoo bah c'est le
compositeur si mature et kate qui lui
est et porte octobre ils ont communié
ensemble pour créer cette oeuvre
c'est ça c'est une collaboration je
dirais peut-être très inattendu un
auteur cri du manitoba vous dites un
compositeur non autochtone canadien de
colombie-britannique la musique
contemporaine provenant de leurs
traditions européennes je pourrais dire
puis un conte qui vient de la mythologie
écrit alors pour vous comme un
réalisateur de fabrique a été le défi de
partir en tournée et de présenter cette
oeuvre à travers les différentes mais
plusieurs défis parce que il faut
comprendre que le sm était une journée
dans chacun des villes la conduira qu'à
ça nous est tous à propos du top mais
rapide comme on les respecte et les
langues mais en fait le grand bonheur
c'était l'ouverture de kent nagano de
nous laisser tomber ce qu'on voulait et
on a véritablement pris ce film comme
dans les grandes années de l'office
national du film avec vraiment pas de
vision préconçues là nous laisser
transporter par l'intuition à tous les
jours faut voir
on arrivait dans une comme on arrive à
saluer le matin avec les émissions de
radio il y avait la rencontre avec les
étudiants dans les écoles les collèges
d'après midi entre les musiciens kent
nagano
il y avait les répétitions de l'arc est
il y avait le concert le soir et mais la
grande beauté de cette oeuvre
et c'était que pour la première fois il
entendait une oeuvre musicale dans leur
propre langue dont évidemment l'opéra
est un cri mais il y à des donateurs qui
accompagne la pièce dont florent vollant
convient
la navale en en innu hermes web un cri
akinésie s'ouvrir l'appliquant ni nos
petits coqs et ça c'était merveilleux
parce que ma crêpe au départ mais comme
le dit qu'un organe ou dans le film il
faut prendre des risques
ma crainte aux dépenses c'est que chaque
à pêche c'est une oeuvre qui peuvent
facile d'accès la première fois c'est
vraiment de la musique contemporaine sur
un compte millénaire et ça a été
extrêmement bien reçue par les
communautés mais on voit d'ailleurs dans
le film d'un croiseur d'abord la
découverte par les enfants ou si on voit
beaucoup beaucoup d'enfants dans toutes
les communautés qui sont qui écoute sont
attentifs on voit un petit garçon avec
un cellulaire il est tellement un bailli
qu'il qui je pense qu'il n'en vient pas
il y avait soit pour la première fois on
voit une violoncelliste également qui a
la chance de jouer avec 45 musiciens de
la rencontre
pourquoi une requête peut être si
important pour faire cette
réconciliation dans le fond parce que
l'intérêt de fonds commenceront à gan où
vous voulez avoir une oeuvre qui
permettent une forme de réconciliation
mais on a c'est la question qu'on s'est
posée au début qui sait que c'est quoi
notre rôle dans ce grand projet de
réconciliation canadien et c'est jusqu'à
un rôle c'est que notre responsabilité
qu'est-ce qu'on a l'occasion de fournir
aux gens puis nous ce qu'on peut faire
si on peut créer des occasions de
partage des changes
on peut créer de l'espace pour des
artistes de différentes traditions et
cultures de partager leur culture
justement dans les communautés on a pu
en chant chaque village qu'on a visités
on a pu recruter un artiste local
oui pour venir se joindre à leur caste
refaire une performance que ce soit la
petite fille que dont vous parlez calais
cooper au violoncelle ou un danseur ou
un joueur de tambour
donc on était très conscient dès le
début d'impliquer les gens dans les
danses confuse rassurer les gens doutent
pour vous aussi comme coréalisateurs g
frappier éviter est ce que je peux dire
le piège de la contreverse de
l'appropriation culturelle parce que
vous avez tourné au moment où on est de
vivre canatal seulement dans le filet
comment ça s'est fait tout seul tout
simplement parce que les intervenants
dans le chum étaient des premières
nations ou des genoux et il était là et
puis
[Musique]
le sm même
des rencontres avec des personnes des
premières nations avant de partir en
tournée pour être capable de caunes
établissent les deux véritables de
rapports mois puis justin king y est
avec on a passé une journée avec
eggimann pour qu'elle nous parle du
nunavik nous parle véritablement des
problèmes et ça s'est fait simplement
parce que comme ce sont tous des
intervenants dans l'opéra mais nous on a
continué cette rencontre en les
interviewe ans et ils se sont grandement
libéré et puis là le film on dirait que
la musique a ouvert les portes pour nous
raconter leurs histoires leurs blessures
leurs vies leurs conditions actuelles et
leur candidat ni multigestion soit par
la flore voilà où les hôtes de ce même
heat laurent volant quand il dit après
avoir passé des années dans les
pensionnats il retourne chez lui c'est
la musique qui la musique m'a sauvé mois
oui je suis ivre de liberté alors ça
c'était extrêmement important mais son
aga nos marques fait la comparaison à ce
que le véhicule ou un qu'elle fournit à
morro bay un petit ses parents étaient
agriculteurs
d'autres choses je pense et dit moi
j'avais rien n'est dit quand je me
souviens d'un piano je parte en voyage
qui dit quand je vois la vie du sens que
je me trompe c'est un peu la même chose
alors si cette tournée serre a touché
une seule personne
ce sera un succès parce que l'entreprise
gigantesque pour ces sept on peut dire
c'est presque un cliché de dire si on
touche une personne ça vaut la peine
parlé et je peux dire ça parce que je
pense qu'on a touché bien plus qu'une
personne
les tango ont chaque communauté on a
rencontré plein de personnes pour chaque
performance on avait des collaborateurs
différent des artistes de chaque
communauté les leaders de 2,3 nation
autochtone je pense que et c'est non
seulement heures qu'on a touché en fait
c'est nous qui ont été touchés qui avait
été touché aussi et c'est justement on
parlait de l'appropriation culturelle je
pense que ce qui est important dans
l'appropriation dans l'opposé de
l'appropriation c'est que les deux
parties sortent gagnants et c'est le cas
ici c'est dit dans le film qu'est ce
qu'on peut leur apporter qu'est ce
qu'est ce qu'il nous donne qu'est ce
qu'ils vous ont apporté les autochtones
dans toutes ces communautés où ce film
de tourner ce film
j'appelle ça un film concerne la
cystéine oeuvre moi ce qui m'a vraiment
impressionné de la porte de florent
vollant sait qu'il va parler avec
tellement de glace et de simplicité de
situations immensément difficile
on sent que de la colère en lui qu'il ya
de la violence mais s'est dit sur un
temps véritablement calme
moi c'est l'heure car nous on passait à
travers tellement de volonté
d'acculturation ils ont gardé la volonté
de parler la langue de chanter le chant
de gorge
vous parliez du petit gars tantôt avec
son son téléphone son professeur m'a dit
ils veulent à pour venir au concert mais
quand il a écouté kent nagano qui a
rencontré les étudiants il a décidé de
venir là il ya enregistré le concert
avec son téléphone et puis après il est
allé se fait photographier à côté de
kent nagano
elle m'a dit parce que lui il avait fait
quelque chose pour lui aujourd'hui de
livres 2 c'était vraiment émouvant parce
qu'on pouvait identifier véritablement
un geste et c'est déjà la fin mark pour
vous et qu'est ce que vous retenez de
toute cette aventure qui va continuer je
m'agite avec le fait que le film sorte
en salles ce soit au québec
absolument ce que je retiens je pense de
l' aventure c'est surtout oui ce qu'on a
pu accomplir dans les communautés mais
aussi la réaction de mes collègues dans
l'heure castres je pense que ça a été
une grande expérience pour les musiciens
pour les administrateurs je pense que
nous comme organisation en a
randy et ça nous permet de justement de
continuer de tisser plusieurs liens avec
d'autres communautés on voit le trombone
et ça on est enseignant n en fallait
faire deviner comment on fait le son
assez très très très pédagogique donc le
film est en salles dès aujourd'hui au
cinéma du musée montréal le clapas
québec et la maison du cinéma à
sherbrooke alors dans les coulisses la
création d'une oeuvre d'une grande
tournée dans le grand nord dès et voir
kent nagano à l'oeuvre également dans
toute simplicité
c'est la première fois qu'on le voit de
face à la loi de place et là il ya du
suspense on va cesser là dessus tous les
deux mais c'est quand ils écoutent plus
dit elle est ce que c'est bien le son de
cris à certains moments d'humour
formidable alors essayez de deviner le
sens du combat là mais si vous savez
alors merci marc burg merci roger ça
vous donne vie à ce film même si je m'en
sers oui parce que peut-être concernant
même table